closest resort experience
that's lady gaga singing stupid love
from our sixth studio album chromatica
the album earned her the artist of the
year award at this year's mtv
video music awards but she reveals it
almost never happened lady gaga told cbs
sunday morning's lee cowan
that chronic depression made it almost
impossible to write
she said it got so bad she might not
have gone into a recording studio at all
had it not been for her producer
michael tucker also known as blood pop
and he used to come upstairs and he go
like come on we got to go down
and work and then i'd sit here and i'd
play some chords and i'd start singing
and writing and he'd be like yeah yeah
and he could encourage me
he was just kind of pulling you through
it just he was
it was it was like a baby walking you
know like come on
you're an artist you're an artist and i
would i would i was
but then it would come out you know and
then we'd fill the room with music and
i'd go in there
and i'd lay it down and then i'd hear it
back and i would smile
and i'd say i sound pretty good blood
and he would go
yeah you're lady gaga and then i'd dance
around for a little while
and then i would go upstairs and i'd
lock myself on my porch and i'd stare at
this guy
and i would be sad again she's
i love that she's so candid about so i'm
suffering from depression she also
suffer i think it's called fibromyalgia
where you have intense pain
she has talked about that but because
her music is so good in the way she
thinks she's different she's not like
the other kids in the class
but she's so talented and i really
respect and admire that she's sharing
herself in this it's so important and
you know listen this this time has been
really difficult psychologically for
everybody and particularly for people
who have anxiety and artists i i've
talked to so many who've really
struggled through
you know the last six months i mean to
me that shows the power of depression
you know she's super talented person who
has the resources around her to
to get help and yet still even she is
laid low by this
yeah you know i like that she said that
her producer said yeah but you're lady
gaga yeah
so sometimes even ladies and gentlemen
so you know you're really good
you can do this sometimes you can do
this you like it yeah yeah
or you can hear more of lee cowan's
revealing interview with lady gaga this
weekend of course on cbs sunday morning
if you or someone you know is seeking
mental health resources you can call the
national alliance of mental ill on
mental illness helpline
at 1-800-950-6264 when
1-800-950-6264